[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
hablando del llamado reloj del
Apocalipsis Es una herramienta simbólica
que fue creada hace 76 años y que
muestra lo Cerca o lejos Que los humanos
estaríamos del fin del mundo Pues por
primera vez en tres años hubo un cambio
en la hora del reloj que ahora está a 90
segundos de la medianoche la medianoche
marca el Apocalipsis y nunca antes había
estado tan cerca según el consejo de
ciencia y seguridad del boletín de los
científicos atómicos que maneja las
manecillas del reloj la situación se
debe al riesgo de uso de armas nucleares
en la guerra en Ucrania entre otros
motivos
las amenazas de Rusia apenas disfrazadas
de usar armas nucleares le recuerdan al
mundo que una escalada del conflicto por
accidente intención o falla en los
cálculos es un riesgo terrible las
posibilidades de que el conflicto pueda
salirse de control son altas como lo
dijo el secre general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez en agosto el mundo
entró en un momento de peligro nuclear
que no se veía desde el apogeo de la
Guerra Fría recordemos que cuando cayó
la unión soviética Rusia Se comprometió
a respetar las fronteras ucranianas a
cambio de que Ucrania renunciara a su
Arsenal nuclear que era el tercero mayor
en el mundo en ese momento ha sido
Ucrania entró en el tratado de no
proliferación nuclear Pues en 2014 Rusia
violó sus compromisos al anexarse crimea
y ahora las situaciones mucho más tensa
pues incluso las centrales nucleares de
chernóbil y saporilla han resultado
envueltas en el conflicto arriesgando al
mundo a la liberación generalizada de
materiales radiactivos a esto se suma
según los expertos un freno en la lucha
contra el cambio climático justamente
por concentrar esfuerzos en la guerra
si empezamos a ver un intercambio de
armas nucleares Es probable que veamos
una guerra nuclear lo que es
extremadamente preocupante
luego la segunda amenaza no menos
importante y es que no es solo el riesgo
de detonaciones explosiones y radiación
de lo que todo el mundo es consciente
sino también los efectos climáticos
globales que podrían matar a miles de
millones
los expertos señalan que una combinación
de guerras crisis climática y una
continua lucha entre los estados por los
recursos naturales que pueden llegar a
escasear son definitivos para acercar a
la humanidad a la hora del Apocalipsis
vamos ahora a Reino Unido para conocer
la impresionante historia de Toby hops
un tierno niño británico que es el
integrante más joven de la asociación
internacional de superdotados a los dos
años aprendió a leer por sí mismo y
ahora que tiene cuatro cuenta hasta 100
en seis idiomas para pertenecer a la
asociación una persona debe obtener una
puntuación de 98 o superior en una
prueba de inteligencia aprobada Y Jobs
fue aceptado a los 3 años cuando se
comprobó que cumplía con los requisitos
fuimos a una librería Y le dijimos
tienes 10 libras Escoge el libro que
quieras eligió primeras 100 palabras en
mandarín que es un pequeño libro le
dijimos Mira este otro libro es un
adorable historia Mira las imágenes pero
nos dijo No este es el que quiero la
asociación a la que te doy pertenece
cuenta con 120.000 socios pero nunca en
su historia había tenido un integrante
tan joven como él según sus padres El
pequeño ya empezó con la saga de Harry
Potter y a veces Escoge libros con temas
difíciles de comprender incluso para los
adultos de Reino Unido vamos a Países
Bajos para conocer el robot explorador
que desarrollaron estudiantes de
irlandeses se trata de un Rover
eléctrico diseñado para resistir las
duras condiciones atmosféricas en la
antártica y recopilar datos sobre el
cambio climático en el Polo Sur se llama
Ice cube y fue construido en dos años
por Tim polar un grupo de alumnos de la
universidad tecnológica de endowen
actualmente no existe nada como nuestro
vehículo en la antártica y no hay
vehículos eléctricos en este entorno lo
que usan Ahora son estos vehículos muy
grandes que funcionan con combustibles
fósiles de los cuales por supuesto
queremos hacer la transición hacia un
sistema de transporte más electrificado
en el Continente el Rover podrá llevar a
cabo investigaciones independientes de
forma Autónoma al no ser tripulado y
cargarse con energía solar lo que vemos
en las imágenes es el prototipo que fue
probado en Noruega en entornos remotos
en donde se comprobó el correcto
funcionamiento de las baterías y de
otras martes que al fallar fueron
retiradas al comienzo el proyecto
contaba con seis voluntarios Ahora tiene
27 integrantes activos Y aunque el apoyo
técnico provino de la universidad la
mayor parte de la financiación viene de
patrocinadores y fabricantes de piezas
se espera que el prototipo completamente
autónomo sea aprobado en la antártica en
los próximos años
finalizamos en los suburbios de la
ciudad estadounidense de Houston en
Texas para conocer la primera casa de
dos pisos impresa en 3D se trata de Un
diseño de la arquitecta Leslie lock que
cuenta con unos 370 metros cuadrados y
tiene un diseño de estructura híbrida en
hormigón y madera
en general es un proceso de construcción
mucho más rápido y también requiere solo
de 4 a 5 personas como personal en el
sitio para imprimir una casa completa
uno de los beneficios también es que la
impresora hace el trabajo pesado el que
haría el ser humano entonces se lo quita
y lo hace la impresora
es clave que la tecnología ayuda a los
trabajadores para mejorar su calidad de
vida pues la impresión de la estructura
de la casa Solo requiere de 330 horas de
impresión se trata de un proyecto que
permite estudiar las posibilidades de
construcción 3D Para futuras iniciativas
principalmente los responsables buscan
que estos inmuebles sean resistentes y
duraderos Incluso en presencia de
huracanes o fuertes tormentas
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en France 24 y 24
punto com
[Música]